Hello? Hello? No, it's so cute. What was her name again? Straw something? It's been a
long time. I think we're about to be up. I have turned down the background so much. Who
was it again? I don't remember but I know she doesn't hate us. She's my darling Rieflin.
It's going to be a very strange stream because I'm on the left side for once but it's because
the map is bottom right and I don't want to intrude. Good morning. Good evening. Good afternoon.
I'm a little honey bun. Today we are not getting educated and the reason we're not getting educated
is because five hours ago I opened up my document to make the presentation for the stream. I typed
in how do we make bridges and my head almost exploded and I was like hmm this education
stream is not going to work out so it's just getting completely replaced. I kept delaying it.
I kept delaying it. I was like I just need one more day to sit down and get all the information.
One more day I'll gather the information. One more day. No, it's getting squashed. Now we're not
doing that education stream. I'll talk about my special interests and stuff that I want to educate
you in on another stream but the uh however bridges built and why the onions make its
prime when we cut into them. No, it's still happening. It's still happening. It's still
happening, son. Right. I have a very important clip you all need to see.
So I'm gonna peel back the curtains just like I'm gonna peel back your foreskin this afternoon
when I take those pictures. Um the girls so what happens is you clip the girls and then the girls
can see those clips and they send them to me okay and I go get them edited. AC sent me the most
redonkillous moment I think I've ever seen occur on a stream and I'm literally gonna send it to you
because I was creasing in my little gamer chair at this freaking clip that someone did of our
like midstream hours he horned so we're all gonna watch at the same time right click that and then
click pause whatever don't hit play yeah I'll tell you when to hit play we'll say three two one play
okay and we can just laugh at the ridiculousness what occurred on this stream I literally said to
AC I'm he horned right he's ready three two one go
oh
why was any of that in your stream it was just so fucking random
oh I didn't expect that and it's the affliction in her voice as well
oh my god like I just like when I go like when the girls submit clips you know sometimes it's
like a funny ha ha moment some of the clips you know can't be turned into a short just one reason
or another and obviously that's not getting turned into a short but I was absolutely he horned
over it I was just the way she was that's just the next back to but yeah AC got the drip rip
I assume right we're gonna see how this game goes ready ready so this is a tutorial
why is that not register nothing okay there we go sorry uh yeah the memory card real and true
yep memory card this is uh the hardware yep that's me spanking the hardware this is real
so super monkey ball deluxe was a game that came out on xbox original many moons ago
um strutting you need to make noises like that
sounds like a chameleon um hi mommy how are you uh I'm very tired but I'm very happy to play this
game we're gonna play story mode I'm not I can't remember nothing I'm just here for a good time okay
scrawny coded game playing mobile that's my secret cap I always play with balls okay there oh my god
can I even fit my names to read or knit knit oh okay right um
uh okay then I guess I'm just fish today uh
uh fish it is yep already
I'd remove one in oh that would have been a lot smarter than just calling myself fish
oh we have campaign oh my god look at those pixels there's three of them
oh my god there's no sun oh we're going down like Led Zeppelin oh wait no no Zeppelin was the
balloon pipe was it no and then they never made another one but they were saying it's safe today
what is this I don't remember any of this
bananas on this island are all for me the great scientist
dr bad food people of the jungle island if you hate me you will starve
he's giving the good suck
do I need to turn up the game volume about
stop it mr bad boon everyone is gonna hit you
shout out shout out you insulate monkey if you want the bananas you need to come to me
I will put all the bananas in my labyrinth that's a big word for a child that you can
comprehend and me is however do you think you'll make it out alive
you can't tell me I'm just a little monkey oh the Hindenburg sorry
yep
dr bad boon you won't get away with this
oh step jump jump who what the fuck let us corporate
this is definitely a japanese game what the fuck were those translations
what was that
oh it's like gacha porn okay this is definitely a japanese game um
um difficulty one banana
let's see how this go
return to monkey what have I seen I don't fucking recall any of this
so this game is literally this like this is it it's like a tilt tilted thing
and then you just go through the bull you can collect the bananas if you want but
I've no idea but like they even have an action new place so yeah this is the game um I remember
I don't know what I remember I don't remember much to be honest I'm kind of sunlocked right now I
didn't didn't know what I was getting into um even not like yeah ready oh my god I was not smart
oh shit oh all right okay it's like the dark souls oh my god it's the dark souls yes we try
oh my god it's dark it's literally dark souls okay pick up the banana okay we're gonna pick up the
banana but you sound kind of out of it today
uh I hope no I'm trying to wake up I'm exhausted
it's so obvious I'm sorry I'm exhausted I don't want to worry anyone but I'm fucking exhaustive
um I didn't sleep well I've been having really bad sleep I've been
just being a wee warrior as always um this game will wake you up I can hardly commentate right now
um I'm going to do a cheeky two hour stream then we're going to redirect into sheepsters we always
worry about you no no it just so I went sorry I'm going to drink my tea sorry sorry pause the
absolute 10 out of 10 gameplay um just if you get bored just look at the little monkey dancing on
the screen look I'm go hey hey go go go um but yes unfortunately I'm extremely tired I'm emotionally
exhausted um I did a lot of background work only there was not one thing to show any of
of it yesterday I think that's probably the worst thing about delayed gratification when it comes
to work is I can do so much in the background and there is nothing to show for it for weeks or
months or days away type thing and it's a it's a wee bit soul crushing just a wee bit
just a wee bit but that's okay um but the girls are going to get loads of shorts soon
um I've sent away the next batch uh I'm going to start sending away their emote batches um I spoke
to sheepsters if you didn't know sheepsters um model actually looks like her now oh my god five
head moment um I did say to her uh I'm very sorry but it's going to take a hot second before we can
change your emotes to look and reflect like you that's not a sentence but try again delayed
gratification is that a reference to the hit game balutroll actually it's okay we know you've
been a good girl even if it's in the background well so I had a sleep for five hours um if that
but I've been having a really light sleep so I don't even wake up feeling refreshed and Jimmy
Beezus at 28.6k oh my god two months and finally someone at vealer got a fucking viral shot it took
long enough um I'm so happy for Emmy I'm so bloody happy for Emmy um she's actually recorded
two three more um that I think I'll do rather well one in particular you guys are gonna love
because I loved it um but I'm so happy that someone finally got a viral shot it took long enough
um it's so hard to figure out what the algorithm wants in that very moment but Emmy managed to
hit it so fucking hats off to Emmy or Jimmy Beezus you like to call her for some reason um
a I want to give you lots of hugs and pamper you well the plan of action is I want to play
super monkey balda luxe for two hours okay I'm gonna go for a nap I'm then coming back on with
Arissa and she's my fantastic shorts editor and she's absolutely lovely it'll be the first time
we've talked and interacted but you know when you know when you meet someone and you're just like
both the years are on the same wavelength that's exactly what I get from Arissa um
and I adore her already and I've literally never even heard her voice in a voice call yet
um it's very nice when you kind of come across these people um where it's just like both the
years are on the same wavelength you get it you're both mature you know what's up like it's just really
never meet your clippers no Arissa's lovely to work with she's fantastic two kindred spirits
it honestly I don't know I will find out after the freaking collab I'll be like no I don't like
Arissa you're fired because we couldn't pivot the furniture in this one game it two great
friends excited to talk for the first time it's very nice um can't wait for vermin tide two yes
vermin tide two is happening tomorrow 100% I'm not swapping it out um I just need to
basically my job is after I've pushed the foes of my derriere is quite literally I'm brushing up
on vermin tide two to make sure I don't embarrass myself in our group session together um it's
Arissa of each of her Arissa is going to be day beautying at a later date we will do a watch
along when she does because I adore her and I want to give her all the kisses in the world um
but at the moment no I don't know she's not actively being a pngtuber at the moment as she was
but then um she'd rather debut and then put her all her effort into streaming rather than being
split right now between like should I do png tubing should I do this should I do that uh no
she is a bit split and um I have to commend her for being able to analyze content like that because
she is she's right in her decision sorry sorry to be sorry to be an analyzer of content for a
moment but um no she is right if you know if you're in the stages of getting a model but you don't
want to you know stretch your time to thin will Arissa be debut and undervealer no she's Arissa
no she's Arissa um she's analizing Arissa replays and carry environment type as long as the game
doesn't crash mid-round I hope not I don't I don't see why it would Arissa for gen 4 gen 1.1
someone asked that I don't know if it was a website inquiry recently or something it was like
um I'm aware that you want three gens I was basically asking for a spin-off gen if they
didn't get in at any point and I and I was like I can't I can't do anything with this I can't reply
to this I was like no there's no spin-off gen I'm Rizzler Arissa yes the ballgame yes ballgame
I'm just drinking my cup of tea give me a moment hi Sturney have you been it's not too I'm not too
far into vermin tide so I don't even have good enough gameplay and yeah it's a play oh no no no
we can put it on easy mode I'm sure vermin tide has a level setting throw me on easy throw me
on the one that gives health temporary shield or whatever it was I see I made it in time yes I'm
chugging my tea um and then we're gonna get into it and hopefully I'll sound a bit more awake but
I do apologize as I found it sounds like a sleepy head you'll never guess why it's almost like the
lack of sleep is catching up to me oh well I woke up a 15 minutes before my alarm so that's a lot
better than a freaking hour before the alarm you don't think easy mode's gonna protect me from the
rats I swear if Estabanz in that game she's gonna win against me don't apologize tea drinker how do
you
um apple brandy is that hyena it is your profile picture is a hyena that's a weird hello Sturney chat
hi riftland thank you for the extended membership apple brandy oh thank you to the riftling who
sent me the unity edit oh my god open up my marshmallow in between all the tentacle picks
and then someone's like hey someone made this I think you'd really like it and now I have a unit
and I love it I'm gonna get it commissioned because I love it so much and I love unity
okay I say what I said I love it look at it it's so cute and then I made the incanimal and by I made
it I mean I cropped it out and then squished it so it was the same width and height it is time for
monkey business you're absolutely right velar absolutely
but yes we have inkling when we're if you zoom in you can't really see it that well but if you
zoom in one of your tentacles has frosting on it in the picture do inklings really send you
tentacle pictures yeah I had someone sent me a really detailed freaking audio oh my god it was
like six minutes of rambling and the reef one was so nice it was like oh thank you for being you
and I'm like oh um I get pictures I get videos are your audio wars I'm a soccer for audios
Johnny I love your recent to air pause I'm glad because you're gonna die by the end of today
because today's the day after the evercicle lab I might have a little nap and then
and then I thank you all for 20,000 subscribers
today's the day
in inkers undivided aw inking unit momy cake
such a great game yes it is okay I'm halfway finished my tea I chug now
my body is ready I'm staying awake oh no I need time to like do it so basically I do the
evercicle lab and then a nap and then I wake up and then I have to like set up the tripod put
clothes on if I want to put clothes on but I'm not I don't think I'm gonna put clothes on I don't
know I have some cute outfits maybe maybe some will be close some not I have to do the body right
and then I have to do the oil and then I have to put on my PC and then you put freaking hidden
watermarks on it so if there's any stinky thieves don't steal it
that's a milder day what a wonderful day AC's close to 10k if you'd prefer an ASMR
experience right now over my greeting voice um icicle snowpaw sorry ac snowpaws that's her
the twin's name um link in the description below she's doing ASMR right now um and she's having a
very good time I believe it's on alternative twitter um I need to submit my documents for the
blue site to get approval on it so I can conduct myself can you lower the volume a tiny bit of me
or the game that was the game by three decibels best way to in spend my day was like oh no I hope
you feel better so in refland the game well I kid you not the game is turned down by 26.2 decibels
at the moment uh player blue site be paid I don't think so I don't think I'm gonna charge for it
I'm just going binchini binchini um if anyone's expecting uh what maybe mercy and shibi has
done uh I can't do that because my clam and uh everything's tight okay I'm not in the good
way so I can't do that stuff how many audio bars like what does that mean we would never
quiet you or quit me
I love how the monkey is busting it he's literally the first fortnight um
while you're in game it's even louder oh my god maybe she's turning it down even more
it's starting to play with falls tonight I sure hope so a little refland okay I'm gonna turn it down
even more wait I don't know what they did so I have no expectations I want to play the orc game
I said it I said it we're gonna play it we're gonna play the orc game something about massage
in an orc or something but it turns out the orc you know it's a chick and she has an attachment
I don't care I don't care if it's controversial we're playing that game I have an interest in it
no not a bum on the orc game isn't it not like it's a chick but she has an
attachment or am I going mental orc or orc orc orc orc orc orc orc orc is that sound really
similar does it sound like I'm barking at you right now I thought you said orc no the orc game
I don't know I have no clue what game you're talking about well we're just gonna have to find out
together then the orc is the wait what I thought it was a chick and she had an attachment
meh I'm sure I'm gonna throw that game in the bin what the fuck I thought it was a chick with the
are you there she's obviously saying orc no the orc is wait what maybe it's a mod
I mean
or am I supposed to role play while I do it and then that's what that feels I'm
going about to sneeze in my tea okay there we go oh Markiplier played it what the what isn't it
wait wait hold on a minute isn't orc massage literally about
am I going mental isn't it not a chick I'm going mental I must be violently remembering
are we talking about Mordor uh yeah yeah yeah okay let me finish last sip
that's after the massage what he could get away with it because he was a bigger youtube
Markiplier a freak okay right let's get rolloid into the juicy gameplay that's right this gameplay
you are on you are gripping the edge of your seat who goes there um you're gripping the edge of your
seat oh my god Mercy could not play this game she'd already be violently motion sick
that was bad I don't have motion sickness but we're basically gonna go as hard as we possibly can
I don't know how far we're gonna get we seem to be in world one I have no idea how many worlds
there are but um on the topic of barely allowed games heard of only cans Thursday it's free and
quite a trip is it bannable or is it playable oh my god we're claptrap oh my god wait it actually
is a map where you have to go up and I was looking to see if I can find some endurance streamers that
would play oh why aren't you moving bro go up okay there we go um I was gonna see if I can find some
endurance streamers that would play uh Borderlands 2 with me um now I might be able to convince
she be to play it but it's it's a bit the the problem is is if I don't want to start it and then
we don't complete it but I don't want to bum rush the campaign either and I'm like did I just play
the reflands and we just played the Borderlands 2 campaign and because we I mean I could make it
happen to be honest once the the throw away steam account is made I can pretty much do anything I
want with you I mean that's the end goal baby but um yeah the entirety of Borderlands 2 I think
it'd be hard to change people out that's the thing I could do like maybe two hour sessions
and then after the two hour mark we swap to the next but then if your character is a low level
oh I don't think that would work that was a quick one you can already do whatever you want with me
um starting BL and not finishing it is a very funny thing yes I in particular don't really like
doing that so I do want um to finalize it if that means you know putting out a tweet and being like
hey I'm looking for endurance streamers um it might have to be she be can do insurance endurance but
I think it might also be good if the VTubers also played the game before so then it's also a
nostalgia pretty much a nostalgia for everyone across the board you know I'm yours to use as you
wish two hour sessions with my man I couldn't last two hours borderlands 3 has level scaling so
dropping out works much better oh maybe we'll play borderlands 3 together why do you need to do
antenna recession no I'm not gonna ask VTubers to do antenna recessions what I don't want is to
pick up borderlands 2 only to for it to be impossible for us to all come together again
and finish it I don't want to start borderlands 2 and be unable to finish it okay this game has a
remake this game was already remade
this game has a remake
hats and Mika please tell me you're joking right now hats and Mika
wait I don't have to play the freaking this version it got remade oh my god I didn't know
no I'm so sorry I was so tired yesterday I was like I just need any game that doesn't
have thinking in it I didn't know you got doctor's appointment okay time for me to put my
thank you I am so sorry I didn't know I don't remember the remaster in this is it on
any folks team time sorry that was such a massive oversight from me
super monkey ball banana banana mania what banana mania was released as a remake in 2021
how's it hectic I don't care about that
hello nurse hello patient uh turn your head and call are you reading are you gonna read maro's
yes I will I will read maro's whoa we have cutscenes everyone's doing their best to survive
we've got to help get all the bananas back then we have to stop doctor bad news before he causes
more trouble but where is he now I've got a boss fight in this game oh my sweet me me I am here
for you if you marry me I'll give back all the bananas
your words hurt me but it is your fault you must be influenced by this village my sweet
baby I don't think you should live here anymore I will sink this island then my dear you'll see
how strong I am if you won't love me then learn to despise me oh oh oh oh he he he he sorry no
Mimi the fun pictures from reddit meme oh no what have I done no he's really gone man
I'll never let him sink this island sorry ah this is terrible but that's
she emotionally spanked the monkey remember that team you guys taught me what's bank in the monkey
man fucking we're gonna meant doing what's going on oh what a beautiful volcano I'll just put the
super dynamite time bomb right there when this bomb blows up the volcano will we wrap
poor jungle island is gonna sink into the sea
I'm too delirious for this honestly oh no he's British this is he must be here let's go
fire of anger bam bam boo let us cooperate yeah yeah woo magical spell is aye aye poo what the
fuck okay okay speaking of monkey thank you hatsun miku the hit aim superstar aim
for the the super chat thank you I really like your set your song in particular uh like
po-pa-po like the world is mine uh also like uh the I'm thinking me me go eat why whoa why is
it so hard all of a sudden oh my god oh my god they're actually making me think now oh god that
is so terrible right at the end fall out okay it's okay we had the ring on us we did it for
middle-earth okay viva viva viva happy can I like do this okay right I was just a test
it was just a test it was just a testicle okay one test that's all difficulty to beneath two
bananas I thought I could maybe jump across I'm sure I've seen like some players like do some
crazy like off the map stuff but I guess you need a certain amount of speed because
um there is actually uh a speedometer wherever it's called wait hold on let me move myself
hey you guys mind if I just sit on you for a little second like like here you guys mind if I
sit right on you because there's literally a speedcam thing I don't know maybe I should go over
should I go there like can you see the can I just sit on you okay I'm just sitting on you it's fine
excuse me what kind of map is this oh my god he's smiling at me sit on his moment
by all means oh whoa whoa whoa whoa it doesn't like oh my gosh
bro we can get anywhere this is turning into a zazzar real quick okay
hey mommy I can't see the game uh wait am I in the way or is it because I'm sitting
I don't know where I put myself this is one of those games where it's like really difficult
I didn't want to be like right guys here's the gameplay and what what wait what you thought I'm
I'm a litchu bar oh um why did you think that I have no idea um anyway so this is gameplay uh we're
just um where the heck I didn't pay attention to where the the thing is I have no idea oh sorry
I forgot by that part my design um I have no idea where the the thing is I'm just gonna go this way
and hope for the best I actually hold on I'll move myself in a sec oh there's a ramp okay that's fine
where is it oh there is uh oh my god I think Mercy would throw up within like five seconds
I'm playing this I'm too sorry darling oh I need to make sure she's not watching the
oh how are the snippets feeling by the way someone okay
fit yourself in the ball be the ball I don't know maybe this isn't too bad just a little a little off
the side remember that time this game got remastered and I didn't hear about it and now I'm playing
the older versions yeah yep I remember do you remember oh my god we're doing some we're doing
the oh my god we're literally doing that motorbike thing where you have to like go around to pick up
momentum oh well I lost momentum hold on wait why am I doing this so terribly wrong
bruh not me getting soft lock well it's not really a soft lock if I suck at the game to be honest
how how am I to get up
get up get her up okay there we go a little disaster
they are adding sonic skin to the remaster this will be what mersey late when you're half a second late
now kiff actually since the ball is always on the same spot of the screen you could crop or
just your head and put the ball over the ball I'm I'm so sorry I am too tired to figure out what an
earth you mean but I thank you so much for your interest what kind of maps are these why are
they in so hard thank you for the extended membership kiff I'm sorry I I didn't have a
brain cells I don't have nothing I ain't got a single thing right now going for me
don't worry we wouldn't have good at even with your tires right what is the deal with this map
hey Lois remember the time I just go on the outskirts
super monkey ball deluxe I don't know if I get anything better than the original version while
thinking that it was the only version and looks oh why are you so doing that don't do that again
but your model in the middle of the screen wait you want me put me in the ball you want me to go here
is this what you this surely this isn't what is this what you meant did you mean this
I don't know I don't know if this is what you meant
wait a little bit is this what you meant I don't know
this is the peak feature where you might not like it but this is what it is okay
okay wait where am I supposed to go oh hold on
is this I mean if you're happy with this shit I can't even get up this down around
okay we did it we did it is this the one on
all right hold on I can make it more entertaining hold on let's do this
she's in a jar stop it really we did it oh god oh god the skills oh my god I'm pushing
so hard right now oh I don't know how I did that I'm zooming in hands I'm picked so perfect
do you like my hips way I can do your hips I can't even fill that ball you and a fish tank
I mean I could technically hypnotize you from this far away
didi didi
wait what's this I wasn't paying attention hello
uh what oh whoa yeah I'm not surprised I was falling what even was that
bruh what even was that now hold on a minute let me get out of the ball what even was that
Matt are you serious what was that I don't I'm gonna pop myself right here did you see that
what am I supposed to not even tell a little bit to the thing
I'm just I'm not touching it I'm not doing anything am I drifting to the left a little or am I making
that up I'm not touching it I'm not I've not changed the pixel this game it looks like it would stress
me out so much that was bizarre that random dive okay we're fine that was a very unique one
speed now you're drifting joycon drift I can't I'm squiddling right now
in that video game bomb it tiny spiny wait how did I not hear your tip
am I going mental or did your tip not play or did I just not hear it because I'm deaf
Brian are you squiddling me right now why can't I hear that hey Lois remember the time
strony didn't know super monkey ball deluxe had been remastered and played the original
version while thinking that it was the only version and looked silly nah and
and it worked okay I can't hear it because this game is actually so loud it's destroyed my headset
volume levels I was so deep in thought thank you tiny spany I'm so sorry I did I've had to lord
the headset volume so badly we heard I don't know why the pierr's griffin laugh broke it
holy crap Lois remember that time strony
this is awful Peter remember that time I thought what the heck is this mouth Peter
Peter okay there we go Peter what the heck is this mouth
whoa oh he's so stressed
he's so stressed what a poor little monkey
Peter the monkey ball is here
Peter the remaster of the game is here you don't have to keep playing the old version Peter
he's scared oh
this is making me lose it you better take responsibility
wait how am I making you lose it I'm mucking about what is that map
let's do it thank you for the super chat you better take response how am I making you lose it
if I'm sitting here oh is it because I went bikini mode what
wait is that a joke hold on sorry I got so distracted by the end of this map what
what is going on with the goal post
can I even go on those without being violently thrown off
oh
what wait am I missing something
am I supposed to send it I'm sending it I'm sending it okay what
what
how am I supposed to lock in thank you any warrior take my money funny clean fish I'm a cuddle fish
is there like another button or something oh okay that makes perfect sense because
wait that didn't stop it
what that button didn't stop it
what it slowed this one down though
it slowed this one down
okay okay okay don't write me yet don't write me yet come on come on
this isn't a game it's CBT and you can't trick me why not why can I not trick you
oh my god wait we're actually progressing through the campaign
honestly I thought this was going to go terribly wrong but we're kind of doing it
this is a bumble eating doctor that bumble is going to use this volcano to blow everything up
wait what what did that subtitle say
I'll take you to this stand back
no I can't do it it's too dangerous
here I go
did I see what I think it says
I mean this this game didn't fucking age well but
I'm losing it I'm sick and tired and look it's almost time
bomb bar
I went down like a lead balloon
thank you
I didn't even see what it said well the subtitles are so fast I think that was just uh
wait so well where in the world is dr. baboon we've got to capture him
hey look over here and dr. baboon's airship is drifting over the ocean
I found him no she found him he is by the airship
what
those monkeys are coming I've got to get out of here
nope dr. baboon you're not getting anywhere dive into the sea splash slash shoe
let us cooperate yeah yeah who magical spellers
oh I'm having a good time that's the main thing I'm having a neat time
if they can fly if they fly why do they ring it literally
these are starting to get a bit difficult okay that looked a bit twisty and bendy
you know what I'm saying it's a bit twisty why poo I assume because it's a wings game
okay surely I can just oh whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa wow wee wee wow I'm turning into
oh stop stop stop stop stop stop stop stop stop okay there we go we're good we're good
oh like as we dance I just caught that he went like
follow your instinct oh yeah hard to swap spell for underwater needs to rebreather function
well we can do it mommy can't swim so what they did was basically self-deleon
I hope you know rather this map is called repo speaking of pulses what's happening
stop stop I've definitely been feeling
like myself and feeling myself um
even though I am exhausted and delirious and drained emotionally and physically
I'm having a good time I hear the
wait why isn't excuse me wait what stop wait no I'm not gonna make it
it I send it oh my god did you see that it was literally trolling me
a mummy needs to be tucked into bed
that was absolutely troll levels on that one
um
world three octagonal
okay one oh my god this is oh wait is it the end of the level if you go down no it's not okay
we'll give it yeah sure I don't know if it's actually better just to reset if you end up with
that one okay wait oh my god sorry sorry sorry I can look at the display I can look at the HUD
sorry look I'm a bit special okay I'm a bit special like that okay we need to go straight ahead
maybe we still have time hold on don't write me I'm yet hold on hold on I'm using my display
okay are you doing
I'd really rather you didn't what okay let's not mess up like that again okay
why are you rushing me I'm a child that's so scary okay we'll try again
one zero I fell down nice on my weekend it's over oh no wait wait why I didn't say no it's always
been yet right you know what fuck it let's do a different map let's call it let's do stepping stone
we'll play more balls today absolutely uh
ready I don't know how far we're gonna get but as I said we'll maybe play for like another cheeky
half an hour and then I'll read marshy molly oh right these are getting really hard out of nowhere
can't watch stream stream today so have fun playing with balls even though they are not
mindless thank you for the super chat can't watch stream today but have fun playing with the balls
even though they're not my bro I'm literally losing so badly right now this catch-up on sucks
I suck at this game you're terrible ready okay right we just need to wait for it to come over
okay oh there's a fish in the background do you see it left side the goldfish
are we looking at me oh my god you don't like rotate with the thing
oh my god easy
okay we did it we did it we did it we did it I just got a sense of deja vu
we've been in the place before higher on the street than I said I'm a time super
what the board bend
she bolt on my monkey till I banana bless no don't do that to the monkey right can I very gently
drop off of this one oh no I can't I need like speed to get up the ramp right okay if that's I mean
fuck it fuck it fuck it oh no we said this is fun okay let's try again let's try again
no I'm getting pushed off oh my god I'm getting pushed off it what are you doing
no no again
right okay okay no no no let me try again let me try again I know I can do this one
okay let's try this one instead because there's one behind we just need to
okay okay we did it we did it that was the main thing out out
we did it
okay this is called url okay little little internet reference all the way back then
this game looks so trippy why is there a website don't go on that I don't know why
there's a freaking website I swear to god if it's what does it say
okay wait what is this in game or is this is this emulator advertisement I'm playing on the real
thing what what does that say
what is this is there a wet w what even oh I can't even look at hold on hold on pause I can turn around
super is it super monkey ball okay that makes sense hold on I can't even get up
hold on I need a bit of speed I am speed okay I can't even get up oh my god right
the maps have like become impossible and one thing I finally get up no get me off that
I literally thought it's the official website I literally thought it said like supermarket
a type thing I'm not playing a labyrinth oh my god
fuck it let's do it mad ring the domain doesn't exist well that's what I was saying don't type it
in in case it's like old media and it's like just full of viruses I'm sure
another ring sonic hero surely if I just send it I'll be fine
oh I mean it worked
I mean it worked I ain't complaining
yay
I love that stream so much
I don't think I have the the ability to even successfully do this run
just send it speedrun queen oh thank you thank you I've been here all week
dizzy uh so I just follow the curve
following the curve oh oh yeah mr perp way I've got a burp sorry I burped
okay gently gently easy easy easy easy edge it edge it nope edge it right we're good
good good good good good how many like level worlds are there infotations marks I'm
literally about to finish the campaign mode by accident I don't think I want to
what is even this I'm not supposed to do all of these in 60 seconds
wait that underpass bridge I'm no no way I'm doing that give it the old twisting spin
Am I allowed to twist and spin mirrors?
This one is my queen tip for the world, milledius.
You were there.
Send it, send it, send it!
No, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
No, no, no, I don't, I refuse, I refuse.
I'm gonna send it a little to the right, okay?
I'm sending it a little to the right.
Okay, that was a terrible choice!
Okay, right, okay, what does it mean?
Can I, in theory, wait until it groups together to move again?
So do that, and then it moves, right, and then we'll slow down.
Oh, no, it's moving me about.
That's alright, that's alright, no, it's alright, it's alright.
Oh, alright, no, that's fine, then we'll move a little bit.
Okay, okay, okay, easy, no!
Okay, hmm, I think maybe we just send it.
This is as far as we got as we sent it on the very fourth time.
A little to the right to hit people.
How dare you, that's mine too!
Right, we're just throwing it, I'm just throwing myself at the goal.
Okay, okay, let me try another one, let me try a different one.
I think we can do this.
Come on, come on, come on, come on, give me that gadget phone.
It's called downhill.
Surely, all I have to do is tip forward a little bit and do nothing else.
Oh, no, there's blockades!
Oh, no!
Wait, it only gave me 30 seconds?
It only gives me 30 seconds to do this one?
Right, get back up there, sorry.
Why would you only give me 30 seconds?
Well, this was our Wien's game, what's going on here?
I've got to understand the laws of physics and speed and...
If you're playing Super Monkey Ball Deluxe and you're going 100 miles an hour on this map,
how long does it take you to reach the goal?
Gotta go fast.
Johnny tried to implement herself into my memories by playing all my nostalgia games.
You've discovered what that stuff, what is this?
We're doing it.
It looks like a Rubik's Cube of a map.
And we have 60 seconds to do this.
Right, we're going to cheat.
I think we can do this.
Yeah, okay, now what?
Huh?
What's going on here?
I don't know.
What?
Whoa, wait, I'm so sorry, I don't really know where I'm heading.
I've run the corner?
Right, okay.
Can I just like throw myself off the whole thing?
Oh no, this is the end of it, hold on.
Hold on, this is a rather quirky map, I have to admit.
Oh no, he's going to give me a countdown.
No, don't tell me to hurry up, I'm scared.
Stop, you're making me scared!
Right, okay, okay, we can throw ourselves a little bit off.
Let's try that again.
Keep going down, hey, hey, but actually go down.
No, like throw, throw, actually go down, girl.
Okay, let's just speedrun this section.
I sped run too much!
Okay, we will do a controlled fall.
We will do a controlled fall.
Let's be mindful of how our speed, okay?
Okay, we're going to go back to zero, and we're going to throw.
And then gently, okay?
Oh no, why did you do that?
Mr. Ma, what?
How?
No even, why?
No even, like, when, but how?
Right, let's try again.
Right, slow it down.
Okay, let's try again.
Right, let's try again.
Right, slow it down, right?
And then send it a little bit, right?
And then bonk.
Right, there you go, there you go.
No, no, now you've gone the wrong way, mate.
Hold on.
Look, I've got a speedrun to beat.
Right, just because you didn't want to beat it.
Doesn't mean I didn't.
Right, let's not go flying off the map either.
Okay, because I flew off the map last time.
Don't get excited just because there's bananas.
Easy, right, and then it's here, surely?
Oh, we actually did it!
Oh my god, we did it, we're so smart.
Will she drop this game midway as well?
Relax!
I'm like, I could get 100% the damn thing.
Fucking steady, I'm getting insulted here.
Let's just try Maby.
Let's just try Maby, okay?
Under, oh my god, junction?
Monkey screaming in pain as Mummy tries speedrunnin', honestly.
Wait, I can go backwards?
I saw that, why can't I go backwards?
Easy.
Gently, gently apply gentle pressure to your objective!
Objective, objective, objective.
Why did I say objection?
That word.
I think that was everything.
I think we're about to get a cutscene.
Actually doing it, question mark.
Oh!
What the fuck?
Right, hydration check, darling.
It's been ever since I came in here.
Those monkeys must have given up by now.
Oh, my, I'm giving up by now.
I'll head for my hideout to plan my revenge.
A hee hee hee.
Oh my god, he a frog.
Frog dance.
We finally found...
Give us back our bananas!
Oh my god, it's Ash.
You're still here.
I can't believe it.
What do I have to do to get you monkeys off my back?
Oh well, it's time I bid thee adieu.
Bye now!
So long, everyone.
Hee hee hee hee hee.
Dr. Bad Boon, I'll get you.
Wait, are we going further?
And her east attorney kick over?
I can't breathe.
I think I'm gonna die.
Sheenette.
My head is almost out and I'm only halfway there.
Wheeze.
Sorry.
Why are you so tired?
Anyway, it's time to give up.
You can't get away from us.
Hee hee.
I got you.
Look out behind you.
Behind you.
Come on, Dr. Bad Boon.
I'm not gonna fall for that trick.
You're planning on running as soon as I turn my back, aren't you?
Huh?
Hee.
Oh my.
Wah!
I think I whipped myself.
Oh it's AC.
Oh hello.
Oh boy, it's too late now.
Hang on everyone!
Bob's joining Swallowinners tomorrow?
You mean today?
I think we're in...
Wait, it swallowed buildings?
We're gonna have to stay here for the rest of my life.
But on the bright side, it may be a good thing
since I'll be staying with my sweet Mimi.
Ew, I can't stand this.
Let me out, get me out of here.
Get me out of here, no!
Don't worry, we've got a way to escape.
All of us except for Dr. Bad Boon, that is.
We are starving.
Let us cooperate.
I love that, let us cooperate.
I just love the sentence, let us cooperate.
Okay, let us cooperate.
Any cooperators?
Oh!
Excuse me?
The goalpost is moving, literally in game.
No!
What does this do?
That was a shite job at that one.
Have I reset some?
Okay.
Alright, hold on.
Let me get on you.
Alright, let me get on you.
Wait, are you serious?
Can I honestly not do this?
Sorry, the camera angle is very hard to manipulate.
Wait, can I actually...
Bra!
It's an inch!
It's literally one inch!
Are you serious right now?
One inch!
What am I supposed to do?
I'm...
Bra!
It's one inch!
How am I supposed to do anything with that?
No way!
No way.
Okay, so I have to perfectly...
Time out.
What the heck?
Right, one...
Two...
Three?
Right, I was far too early.
What the heck?
It's literally in the air.
One inch isn't enough to you.
Alright, hold on.
One, two, three!
No!
Far too early.
Wait, we're not doing this one.
Bra!
One...
Two?
I don't know.
No, it's not gonna make it.
It's so hard to control the freaking camera angle.
I'm so sorry.
Ah, I'm too early!
It's not even visible.
Should I just fucking go for this one, honestly?
I'm trying.
I'm gonna stay right here.
I've got a banana though.
Okay, we'll do a different one.
This is impossible.
It's one inch.
How am I supposed to do something with that?
Well, how the tables turn.
Size doesn't matter, she says.
How dare you.
One inch.
How am I supposed to do anything with that?
Did I just do SPH by accident?
What?
We've done block slim before.
We've done that.
We can do that.
Let us cooperate.
Cooperate with you.
Give Stroney an inch.
E E per star.
That's what the game is like.
Hi.
We're almost at the goal.
Every goal is a goal.
Wait, hold on.
One way around.
Every goal is a goal.
Okay, at least we've got one in here.
You saw it here, Chet.
She made one inch of work.
You need some momentum.
Literally, I couldn't even get on it.
Wood dammit.
Jump ramp?
This looks so dangerous.
The difficulty between the maps is astronomical.
Ready?
I don't know what way I'm supposed to go yet.
I don't know what way I'm supposed to go.
Right, I don't normally get motion sick in games,
but I actually think I might be getting mildly motion sick right now.
Not like me.
Wait a minute.
Who are you?
Suspicious.
I'm like, wait a minute.
Is that motions like this?
I don't get motion sick in games.
Mummy, don't throw up, honestly.
Could be your sleep deprived as well.
I might help if you unstretch the stream.
You want me to unstretch?
How am I supposed to fit you?
Oh my god.
I don't know how I got away with that one.
I just literally just went for it.
The word she can say is no take to be your build.
He's tighter.
What the beehive?
The bees?
Hi.
Sleep deprivation can give nausea symptoms?
I didn't know that.
I am pretty sleep deprived.
Right, wait, how or what am I supposed to do?
Can I just go around the edge?
Get me on that again.
Be a lure, spin off.
Like, vomular, spin off.
Right, let's just send it, let's just send it.
Oh, not that fast though.
Right, hold on, hold on.
One more time, one more time.
One more time for the guy in the back, okay.
Is this, how much is there more to campaign mode?
If there's like one, like if this is the last level...
Stop!
Oh my god, right, this is getting embarrassing now.
Stop it, you call yourself a gamer?
What is this?
I'm about to burp and it's not because I've drank anything.
I'm motion sick, what the fuck?
I never get...
Almost gagged there, hmm.
I don't think we can continue playing.
No, oh, sugar.
I don't know what to do.
We might be reading marshmallows.
I think I might be mildly motion sick right now.
What the heck, I don't get motion sick like that though.
Bra.
Come on.
I was like one centimeter off of it.
Oh, right, I keep doing the same thing.
Right, enough, enough, enough, enough.
I think, I think I'm actually gonna have to read marshmallows.
I'm not even kidding.
Yeah, hold on, let me...
I'll be getting all marshmallowed up.
This is when you know it's that's the time, okay?
I'll leave the background game music on.
How about that?
For some ambience.
I'm gonna need a cheeky break though.
I don't feel...
Mr. Stark, I don't feel very well.
Mr. Refling, I don't feel very good right now.
I ain't gonna lie.
Hold on, let me open up marshmallow.
I love marshmallow time.
I'm gonna be able to read any of these out loud.
Hold on, let me just make sure I'm gonna redirect him to sheep's throats.
Sorry, today...
Today I don't feel like doing anything.
Whistle, whistle, whistle, whistle.
Don't feel like blowing up my phone.
So leave a message at the tone.
Today I don't feel like doing anything.
I'm sure she'll be screaming today.
I'm like a hundred percent sure her ass is screaming.
No!
It's two hours later than she normally screams.
Right, everyone's getting put in the bin.
Everyone's getting put in the bin.
I've had enough.
I can't believe it.
I can't believe there's fluctuating.
Oh my god, right.
To the snowberry that sent me a marshmallow calling me an effing R word.
Because for the ASMR train I'm swapping time slots with AC for one stream in a month.
Snowberry, for the love of god, do you genuinely think I'm trying to sabotage AC?
Please, take a moment to think about the words I communicated in the last stream.
I said that the ASMR redirect train does not work for AC because she goes first.
So for one stream in the month, I would take her time slot and she would take mine to ensure that she gets a benefit from the redirect train for one stream.
Fucking relax.
That language you used was abysmal.
You really need to think stuff through.
You can't even be doing stuff like that.
You need to reflect because that was not on par.
I don't normally give people a spanking but seriously that was a bit too far, that marshmallow.
And I think deep down you know that was a bit too far as well because what even was that by any sound of logic.
Why do you genuinely think I was going to randomly swap time zones after establishing, for me personally, streaming every single day?
Why would I establish a time slot where I'm always online and then I would randomly swap it?
Don't be silly, please use your head and don't be so...
Don't act like that because if AC caught wind of what you even sent me in Marshmallow, imagine how she would feel knowing that I got that off of you.
Seriously, use your head.
I don't give spankings often but holy shit.
That was something else.
I can't wait to turn your ass into a twinkie tonight, thank you.
I don't think AC would approve of Billy and Mumme.
Shame on that particular snobbery.
I don't normally give people a spanking, I just leave it.
But because you brought it to my Marshmallows and you definitely said some things that you obviously felt in the moment,
and then when you look at reality it's like holy fuck you've literally just spewed all of this against me.
When all it was was, hey AC doesn't benefit from this thing, I'm going to swap my...
I'm going to go two hours earlier and she's going to take my time slot so she benefits from this thing.
And then I get called an array of shit, I'm like holy fucking shit bro, use your brain.
Five seconds, that's all I have.
Anyway, back to the regular scheduled H time, honestly.
Let me move this over so I can read it a bit better.
Sorry if this is a duplicated message, no please don't worry you can always duplicate.
As a budget link, I'm happy to say that Reeflings can't afford to support you so much.
You deserve the support you amazing giver.
I know you sometimes don't read things out loud that seem personal at least,
I'll just say you can share it in this case.
You put it at the end, I already read it, I read it at the start.
If you don't want me to read it you need to put it at the start.
I read it at the end of your message Reeflings.
You miss, you miss.
But yes, thank you.
No, please don't worry you don't have to hand over money.
You don't have to actually hand over money, I assure you.
Everything's going good, everything's going well.
I don't have any issues, I don't have any problems.
The Veiler Cup program just went up, which I need to deal with shortly.
A paste action on YouTube and I'm like thank you.
Not trying to debate but there's no way I can believe that was a real complaint.
Well, I've got the marshmallow approved but unfortunately.
I think what it is, obviously as most things are in life, one big misunderstanding.
But it was the fact that misunderstanding went so severe to just like straight up name calling,
claiming that I don't want the best for AC and all that jazz and it was like,
motherfucker, I was pregnant with her for one year and you think I don't want the best for her?
Like, who do you think gave her that ASMR script?
Who do you think edited it? Who do you think put subtitles on it so it would get as much traction as possible?
Like, come on, come on.
I don't know what brain worms you guys are fighting over there but holy fuck.
Short your shit out before you start flying shit.
To everyone, I love you all, this is a great place to be.
Maybe PS don't read that.
Hope you're doing okay. Today's my birthday.
He's the jolly good fellow, he's the jolly good fellow, he's the jolly good fellow.
That nobody can deny.
Happy birthday.
I love you so much.
I love you too, a little refling.
Thank you for coming back and spending time with us.
As always, Samwise was the secret hero. Feels good man.
Hey, Strani, I come to you as a humble refling with a humble request.
Let us analyze this request.
You said you had some outfits but please consider wearing a cute pair of underwear as well.
Sincerely, a refling.
Shit, okay.
I just might. I just might.
You were clapping with your hands, but yes I was, I'm sitting down.
This is my hands.
We getting copyright struck with that one, are you joking?
I need to see your cheeks clap strongly.
Or better I make them clap, frothing at the myth right now.
Thank you.
Mummy, I wrote something for you because I'm so brained right now.
Enjoy it.
Hold on, are we doing a live reading?
There's no way we're going to get away with a live reading.
Oh my god, I really am motion sick.
I just looked down at my keyboard there, that really hurt.
Why is it the first sentence I read is,
it's a shame you're such a quick shot cuddle.
Why is it the first thing I read is it's a shame you're a quick shot?
Am I being shamed right now?
I love being shamed.
I mean you are.
Right, but why would that be the opening sentence?
Okay, it's a shame you're such a quick shot cuddle because I would very much like to spend as much time with you if I got the chance.
Perhaps we could snuggle under the blankets on a cold and rainy day.
I told you close to my chest and give you a little kisses on the top of your head.
Oh wait, this is actually wholesome.
What the heck?
Do not worry, the snowberry will be dealt with.
Special forces use Strone's Metapatreon audio as a torture tactic.
Scream in fear at the strome.
No, thank you.
Sorry, I've been a super chat.
Special forces?
Strone's Metapatreon as torture?
Scream in fear at the strome?
Congrats on 21k.
Oh stop, have it actually.
No way, I am so behind.
Oh, I'm so behind.
But that's okay because we're getting to it.
She's a dragon of fire.
Right, where are we continuing now?
I told you close to my chest and give you a little kisses from the top of your head down to your nose
and on to those soft lips of yours, nibbling them a little before making my way down your neck and onto your shoulder.
All the while my hands would explode.
Wait, can I?
Wait, what's the last thing?
I don't think I can...
All the while my hands would explore you down your back towards that peach of yours,
grabbing large handfuls of it, squeezing and massaging each cheek like I was kneading bread.
I'd run a hand along your inner thigh as well, fingers tracing circles around your...
Alright, no, okay, we can't say this, we can't say this, we can't say this.
We can't say that part out loud.
Can't say that part out loud.
Imma read the rest, okay?
I'm back again because your Twitter post inspired me.
I want you to come straight to me after a ring frit stream all sweaty and out of breath.
I don't know if I can read any of the marshmallows.
Okay, what's going on?
The next one, this is how I denialate your holes.
We can...
I don't think I can read any marshmallows.
The next one, I was edging and jerking.
No!
I can't!
Hi, scrawny, hi, reefling, I'm conflicted.
On one hand, I want you to be happy and I never want to upset you.
On the other hand, I really like the idea of you being so angry that you post orgasm part to me.
I can't read any of the...
Oh my god.
Please don't read this out on stream, I'm dying of embarrassment.
Okay, I'm gonna refresh and see if there's anything that I can read.
What would you do or say to win the hearts of each of the Vealour girls?
Okay.
Okay, I can attempt this one.
Um...
So, Emmy, the third one, she's very independent, so...
I just let her do what she wants.
She does whatever she wants.
Um, to win her heart.
Wait, do you mean like romantically?
I'd just...
I'd go up to...
Sorry, let me mute the background just for a second.
I'd go up to Emmy and, you know, she's smaller than me, so I'd lean over, I'd go into her ear
and, you know, I'd, like, lift her chin up, so she's, like, looking up.
And then I'd go right next to her ear and this is how I went Emmy over.
I'd go like this, I'd go...
Or, or, or, or, or, or, or, or, or, or, or, or, or, or, or...
Because she has finnaf brain rot.
Er, Eysical, how would Eysical?
What would I say in Eysical ear?
Er, Ginger, no, she is Ginger but...
a...
Mummy is Lid Refillings or Lidback Mummy.
Ah, it's because I've tried it!
Ehh...
Eysical...
What would I say to win the heart of Aysby?
I just treat her like a princess, there's really not much to it.
Sheebie...
Sheebie isn't that easy
because she has different layers
to what she likes
and it's very mood-orientated with Sheebie.
Mercy, however, is just in a pet place
so she's easy as fuck to deal with.
Azura...
She again has layers to what she likes.
So it's hard to pick on one thing.
It depends on the mood of her, the situation.
Sheebie as well.
You know, Azura claims that
she's dumb, always around women.
So it might be the case of let her do what she wants.
Sheebie has layers, onions have layers.
You get it, right?
You know, Sheebie's an onion star!
You know what I mean!
Just call her Fondaladism.
Layers like an ogre.
I've put that in your head too much.
Sheebie caught in...
Maybe...
I don't know, I think Sheebie has an appreciation
for none kind of stuff.
So maybe I would...
I would throw...
I would grovel on my knees.
I'd throw myself at her on the floor
and basically be like, cure me of my ailments.
And then that's when her nun side would come out
and be like, ah, you lost little lamb.
I will guide you.
And I'd be like, yes, yes, guide me into that hole.
Azura seems to like war.
So maybe I'd let her eat me a little bit.
Just a little bit.
And...
None dorm is a thing, yeah.
Don't...
Guide me to temptation, Sheebie.
That's all I ask.
Okay, amen.
Hey, my man!
Hi, reflin!
I'm just a silly little reflin.
Can I have a hug?
Of course!
Oh, I'm not wearing...
If I was using the 3Dio,
I'd be able to do the hug,
but I can't do the hug.
Because it's an SMB.
I don't know.
Can you tell that I'm hugging right now?
I have no idea if you can tell I'm hugging it.
Ah, Demo!
Thank you for becoming a member.
Please enjoy the emotes.
I'm not sorry about the pregnant one.
It is getting replaced at Lairday.
Or maybe not, I don't know.
None dorm, you say?
Okay, but...
If you aren't dorm, then do you spend me too?
I could be a member.
Let me see.
Also, congrats on 20k.
Thank you so much!
I'm happy I discovered you.
What you have done has helped me a lot.
Thank you.
Oh, thank you!
I'm glad I can help you.
I'm not sure what I've done to help,
but I'm glad I could.
Sometimes,
sometimes maybe just knowing
that there's silly billies out there in the world,
then that's all you need deep down inside.
Be careful when you're breathed into the mic.
Okay, for some reason,
it's ear-to-ear breathing
for the 3Dio.
Ah!
Oh my god, wait, that emotes combo.
Inkling lick turns into pregnant.
That was so good.
Not sure to say apologies
or congratulations on the tight climb.
Pitch of coal up there,
and you'd push out a diamond.
Reef, what the fuck?
I'm speechless!
What if I just read?
Would make a wicked party trick.
Reef blend!
That's hilarious.
That's absolutely hilarious.
Don't type that ever again, though.
Does that make myself clear?
Don't type that ever again.
What was that?
Pressure's so intense, it could be diamonds.
Wait, that's...
Mummy funded me a lot.
Real answer.
Eh...
My injured toe?
What you done to your toe?
Am I about to look at some gross toes?
It's okay, my toe's gross as well.
We can have gross toes together.
We could be toe cross lovers.
Well, you said...
Oh no, wait, hold on, I'm too dumb.
I need to just remove the brackets.
I'm a smart gal.
Oh my god, you fucked up your toe.
You did fuck up, it's all bruised.
Hi, someone says hi.
Hi, Reef blend.
Who stopped her toe? When did we finish it?
She did.
Changes the diamond of meaning in the rough.
I assure you, my guts are nice and smooth, baby.
Hi, Johnny.
Hi.
I want to fill your cake and turn it into a cream puff.
I give you my permission tonight.
Petition to name...
Rename the nether...
To the diamond mains one.
Instead of clam.
A Scottish lullaby singing stream.
Is there even a Scottish lullaby?
I know.
Scottish lullaby lyrics.
Let's see what comes up with this one, I reckon.
The oldest known lullaby
is a Babylonian lullaby found
and scribed on a clay tablet
about 4,000 years ago.
Okay, but what's that got to do with Scottish lullabies?
Wait.
Why...is there not...
There's a lullaby called Dream Angus.
I don't want copyright.
Dream Angus.
Okay, I don't want copyright.
I don't know with Scottish lullaby.
I wish we were so back in the mines.
Just a random something.
What a rare clam.
Most only make perils.
I'll have to investigate thoroughly.
Scottish lullabies be like,
If you didn't go to bed, I'll knock you upside the heat
with my whiskey mug.
Till you honk shoo.
Oh my god.
How we do it? What would the pacing of that be?
There you go.
There's some Scottish lullabies for you.
Just how many special
interests are you going to unlock me?
Brian!
I mean, no, that's true.
That's definitely true.
You have to admit, mommy,
we are the biggest collection of the gems.
I mean, yeah.
But it's not the best part.
That was my desktop appearance.
There's comments and generous donations.
Would you have it any other way?
Would I have it any other way?
Nah, I like how we got it.
We got it.
Yeah.
Maybe we need to do a marshmallow-specific stream.
Unlike here's subjects we should talk about.
Cause, um...
Reeflings reflect the moment.
We cannot be more proud of it.
Just back from sudden Elden Ring myth and error.
Yeah, unfortunately I'm getting motion sick.
I'm not very well at the moment.
Cause of...
I can't believe it.
But there's this thing called exhaustion.
I think I'm starting to hit it, you know?
Forget hitting the wall.
I'm not Hag V Trooper yet, okay?
But apparently,
exhaustion can make you more nauseous
and motion sick.
And I'm messing it up for myself.
Who the fuck?
I'm allergic to seafood
but I definitely eat you till my throat gets sore
and I'm gasping for air. Please don't die.
I don't have an AP pen on me.
Does anyone have an AP pen for that one reefling?
Oh my god!
Imagine getting a random lick
at a convention
and then someone needs an AP pen
cause they lick too.
I hear it really happens a lot
in Super Monkey Vault, okay?
How did they... how did they get past that?
They might be nice people.
Okay, Strawny, reefling.
Uh, how many
special interests are you going to unlock?
First it was backdoor, then it's feet, and now it's pits
and sniffa. Woman, you have no idea how terrible
you're making me. First thing I see in the morning
and it's that art, I want to tie you up, lick you all over
and devour you!
I'm sorry.
By the same time you're welcome.
I'm just broadening
your horizons, okay?
What's life if you can't
enjoy a few of the
spaces it offers on the
site? Huh?
Yeah.
Never let Mercy play this.
She'd be in a coma. Oh no, and Mercy's not
touching this game. If I
literally see her put it in her schedule
it's getting pulled. The first
pulled schedule ever
of Viola, and it's because
it's a motion sick game.
Um...
You down agritus amount
of water.
Uh, I found you
recently and I love your videos. You seem like
fun to hang out with. Oh thank you, I'm glad.
Even though
you've caught me on the worst day though.
Literally like the most exhausted and tired of me
then.
I'm gonna, what the plan
is, I'll get a nap and then
I'll prepare for Arisa.
I'll go harass her. Arisa is
Ozzy, by the way. Ozzy, Ozzy, Ozzy.
Oi, oi, oi.
So get ready for the
Newzanker Australian accent.
Reporting
live here today,
I'm playing with Arisa
on a game called Living Out 2
of something of that nature.
Uh, turns out we both
have access
to Xbox Game Pass
and together
we are going to play the game.
Whether
or not we will be able
to connect with our internet
providers is a different question.
However, we will
try our best.
Okay. I can't ignore that.
I can't ignore the Ozzy
Newz presenter down.
I'm moving into your pants
right now.
I'm just moving into your pants, Diego.
I can give you a bit of space for that.
Um,
yes, that's probably the best accent
I can do for the Ozzy
because it's fucking impossible
to mimic them on a daily
basis.
Um,
it's really hard to mimic an Ozzy accent.
It's next to impossible.
E.
Excuse me,
mommy. My thumb is about an inch or two
long. I can definitely show you what can be
done with it whilst I'm
reeling it from behind.
Oh, uh-huh.
Mm-hmm.
I dare you.
I was going to send a smooth pickup line
I heard recently, but I forgot.
I'm staying awake for it. Oh, I'm staying awake.
I know it's not my usual stream time
aim, but
it would probably be like two hours of shenanigans.
Maybe less than two hours. I'll tell
Arisa what's up. Arisa's not going to be like,
only gets runny. Probably retired.
No, Arisa's going to be like, fuck yeah,
understand.
She sees that mass is online all the time.
Um,
she's really good. She's really very attentive.
You should do a Steve Irwin
watch along.
G'day.
No, he doesn't say that. He does not
say that. Sorry. He does not say
that. That's what Ozzy's saying.
Although he is a certified Ozzy.
Would he say it?
Maybe not on camera. Maybe not next
to the crocodile. Okay.
Think of what Steve Irwin would want.
Okay.
I'm going to get a whole two minutes sleep tonight
for real, for real me. Crikey.
Crikey, she's a beaut.
I'll probably have to watch the
VOD. It's 3am. Oh, yeah.
No, don't, don't force yourself.
As I said, it's not in my usual time
slot. So please don't feel
forced to show up live. You know, you can
always watch the VOD.
A cheeky, you know, special shout out
to the VOD watchers or people who catch me
live. You know what? Shout out to fucking
everyone. Okay. That fucks with me. You fuck
with me. I'll fuck with you. Okay. Getting that
bed right now and take those boxers off.
Okay. You fuck with me. I'll fuck with you.
If it's only two hours, then I'm going to watch it
in bed and keep it in the background.
That fucking restaurant is all right in the
background.
Shout out to the lurkers. Literally, lurkers
appreciate you. Liveers
appreciate you. Voders appreciate you.
Clippers appreciate you.
Commenters appreciate you.
Lakers appreciate you.
Everyone,
everyone that fucks with me, I fuck
with you. Getting that bed.
Don't straw, don't, don't straw
me. I can't even read now. I've lost the ability
to read. Don't worry, straw me.
I will treat you like fine art. Now let
me pin you against the wall and nail you.
Okay. That was good. I'll give you that.
That was good. I'm going to give you
that one.
Maybe, maybe I can pin you to the wall with
my legs. Is that possible?
I don't have upper body strength, but
I might be able to
really mess you up like that.
I mean, I can, I can choke you out.
Yeah. That makes up for it. My inability
to lift you and pin you against the wall
is undone because I have thighs
or something. I don't know. Sorry, I'm starting
to lose the ability to make comprehensive
cohesive sentences.
Okay.
I need to go for it now.
It's not happening.
Just as qualify as story after dark
soon, maybe, sometime.
You say that, but last stream
I didn't stay until the end and the
VOD got taken away. Oh no, those streams are going back up.
Nothing seems to be happening with the
DMCA issues.
So
I am going to
pop it up
soon. I don't, there's no,
the problem is there's
like one VOD that has 50 claims
and if for whatever reason
the studio claimed that my channel
would be gone and it makes me nervous
but I think it's fine.
Okay.
Get some rest.
So because
we played the campaign of Lord of the Rings
it had the actual music
from the movies in it
and it making me
a very nervous, so a private
I would not risk a whole thing
for it personally.
I don't, well nothing's happened.
Now if there was a warning
or a claim
or I had, you know, like I looked up
if other people had played the game and the games are
fully up so it would be very
it would be
an outlier if for some
reason
I got copyrighted
but no one else did
that has all of these things.
Okay, so I think it's okay.
Sony, let us wear her thighs
like a scarf. Occasionally choking is
appreciated.
Whoa.
I need to stretch my own bed.
Token says fuck you in particular.
Can you imagine?
Saron with one finger on the report fund.
I have to see.
Too much talking. Hydration time.
Fine, fine, I'll hydrate.
Okay.
Then it says, it goes there.
I used out some images of you
ready for later but I'm running out of ink
so they look a bit funny.
Wait, wait until
I drop the butt pic.
I'll try and do that as soon as I can.
There's people over at the minute.
Careful, don't get in trouble.
Oh my god, don't
print pictures at work
by the way, they know what you're
what you're printing.
So you know
your work know what you print out.
They can see it.
And they call it a mine, mine, mine
mine, mine, mine, mine
Hi momay, hi
I love you, I love you too.
I think that however
um
Oh, okay, right, that's actually just feedback.
I mean, fuck it, we can discuss it.
Okay, so Riflin says the
Patreon content is too short. I'm not sure
if it's problematical or that
inconspicuous thing. No.
So
I am very aware that
I cannot ask too much of the girls.
Okay, so I can't
ask them to stream and then
a 30 minute audio
does not take 30 minutes to produce
and I know you know this and I'm not
you know, I'm not saying anything. I know
you know that it takes longer.
If I asked the girls to produce
a 30 minute audio
it would take them probably
an hour to record
and now you could
argue, hey, you know
well it's their job type thing
it's in the contract type thing
I have to
enable the girls
to just listen to it twice if I said
I have to enable the girls
now I have not
if they want to make their own
scripts, if they want to go above
and beyond, they can
add live the scripts, they don't have to stick to the
scripts, they can add sections if they want
but I am very
aware I cannot ask too much
of the girls because if I ask them too
much, they are going to be too stressed
and not want to stream, they're going to be
unable to do fun projects
on the side that they want to pursue
collabs maybe with other people
all that kind of thing
when
you know kind of being in
this position, I have to take
stress into consideration
especially for them who have
not moved out in particular
they do not have the freedom
or privacy to record
for such lengths
at this point in time
now I'm more than happy to bring it up
in the meeting if you want me to
see what people's discussions and things are
I do comprehend that they might
be too short but there are so many
factors that come into
why the audios
might be
less than
I am going to aim for more than
10 minutes though, I have
put in a little tidbit for the girls
to be like try and aim for
over 10 minutes
I can slowly
work up to
12 minutes to 15 minutes
15 minutes is probably my hard cut
off because
you know some of the girls
already have trouble recording as it is
you know
and
recording audios as well
does take it out of you
it's not
you pop in the booth and you're like full energy
like no you're fucking like
especially for
those
who are
is it method acting? No, it's not
what is it? Live acting? Whatever
you want to call it okay
it's a lot
and you know
you're trying to do multiple
things at once
but yes I
can definitely relay that I can ask
the girls what they think
what their stress levels are in terms
of how they feel the patreon
audios are going I am more than open to these
discussions
please don't think I'm just going to sweep
it under the work type thing
but just as a whole on the very
surface if you just want to take it at face
value there's a lot of factors
why
I can't actually ask the girls to do a
30 minute audio however
I am not stopping them from producing
that they can write their own scripts if they so desire
I am aware I think some of the girls
actually are writing
scripts with you in their member
streams possibly
but yes there's a lot
of factors to why
and
they do their own stunts
yes they do their own stunts
and
yeah
yeah no I'm open to
discuss and look kind of
your climate
would say it would be best for making perils
yeah but the peril is
slang for something else
so
hi momay hi
weflin weflin here
just wanted to tell you
something is super important
inks on you you know what
I'll ink on you twice as hard
if the girls are more comfortable and are interested
they could ask for it yep absolutely
they want to pursue that that's not a problem
by me at all
no issues
if you are streaming
right now to all the reeflings
in chat say love you strong
if you are streaming
right now I am
to all the reeflings in chat
say love you strong
what
you guys say love you strong
love you reefling
aww that's so adorable
maybe maybe we have
proved that it's
streaming live and it's not just
a pre-recorded stream
how dare you
forget diamond the pressure
your TAKE CLAMICS AIR
could create a black hole
from any piece of matter
that destroys the earth so it's
very kind in magne
what is this word
are you guys giving me new vocabulary
I'm posting it in chat right now
why does it have a link
stop
how do you guys know the words
what
what the fuck it sounds like a pokemon
it literally sounds like a pokemon
I choose you
magnanamouse and it's like a fire
most hate pokemon
fire normal type pokemon
hold on it's very important
it's very important
oh wait
are you squidding me right now
magnanamoo
oh no
I'm so sorry
the brainwrote is spreading
thank you john omni
who goes there
I'm sorry
I'm so sorry
actually it's not pressure that causes black hole
it's math oh excuse
this is how I say it
magnanamouse
get brain worms
no get ear worms
but it's like something that I say that you see
who goes there identify yourself by the poop
I love by the poop
yabam I've not said that yabam that much
yabam
let me take your order
oh I'm sorry
use tts for pronunciation
magnanamouse
boo boo boo
huh
strony brainwrote is real
the vocal fries
I can't stop thinking about you
you always talk about how stinky and sweaty you are
and you're such a nasty pop
oh no you can't stop
you can't start calling me pop
okay cause that
stop it
bad refland
don't call me pop
I don't think there is strony brainwrote
but why not
why not
because
it's bad
and that makes me shy
and I can't be shy and stream at the same time
it's not possible
not my eyes
don't call me pop
what are you
what are you called for
it's cuttlefish
it's called strony
I'm shalissa
who's shalissa to me
hi momen
I have a confession to make
I'm not sure how you've given me a kiss
in special interest
I have your latest celebration
ASMR saved on my hard drive
as personal encouragement in my alone time
the things you can do to recent friends
ah
the cuttle pop
love the french
our pop is getting reversed
stop I can't read that
stop don't get brain to say it
good pop
don't get brain
in on the freaking
the freaking pre
stop it
stop I'm going for a nap at this rate
I would never be a simp
strony appears whatever you wish my queen
oh my god
soundproof con booth win
I think we have to
unofficially go to a convention
I'm gonna be honest
the plans that we're
the things that we're coming up with
we're definitely doing an unofficial
appearance there is no way
we are getting away with what I want to do
not possible
it is
speak up pop
shut the fuck up
dying yoda falling off the map
lego sound
stop
stop Brian shut up
our pop is so adorable
shut up Brian
I want to hear it
thank you broly legend
any news on the call or no
not yet I've not had shipping confirmation
actually I'll message them
I'll message them
momet mithlyn your twitter post
hit me right in the scent
special interest I love it so much
I've inked three times
I want to know have you always
had a scent thing or you develop
one just for us I always
enjoy like pheromone stuff
Brian no
who's a good pop
yes you are yes you are
want to go for walkies
you know what
you can whip me
you can whip
I'm gonna start swinging
the beauty story thank you
and I'm in it
you can whip I'm actually gonna start swinging
I'm actually gonna become scottie
put my accent on so none of you can
know what I'm on about
for like half years that I'm not even comprehensive
of the scottes line
you're all getting swing down
a bit of fisticuffs
someone's getting fisted by the end of the night
and it's no need
you can't beat us
thanks for all your hard work
thank you
it's really worrying
me how bad you're feeling even if I know everything
will work out then wish you the best
remember you know where to find us never doubt yourself
cause you're doing great love you love you too
I'm sorry I don't want to
see this is why I'm trying to find the balance of like
oh
I don't want to stress you's out
day 36
we're begging for full scottese
you don't have to beg for it it's already been cooked
don't worry
21k reflans calling you a good pop
you think you can beat that
I don't want to take it
so I don't know if it happens for guys
but can you experience
tingling on your tentacle
is that a thing for guys
or is it only women
I don't know
21k
oh you can
ok right
it goes both ways
it's a twitch
you mean the hit youtube
the hit website twitch
it goes both ways then
because when you guys start
when you start
doing the whole pop thing
I get tangles and it's really hard
to focus on streaming
do I make myself clear
so knock it off
because it's hard
difficult
I'm trying to smoke and sing
you want game suggestions
sheepie a short adventure
is it gonna be offensive
I'll write it down on my list
but it's fun to tease you
no mom I'm sorry
I want to write down
I've wrote down sheepie a short adventure
so you're saying we're turning
stop it
stop it it's turning me on
what does that mean
stop it stop saying that
you're turning me on
what's your opinion
on lemon and lime pizza
that's not even a thing
you're just winding me up
the strunnies wearing me the don't bully shirt
why are you bullying me
liquid ones snow
are you squidding me right now
on brian
stop it
brian
the fact you shamelessly say it out loud as well brian
as the fucking sprinkle on top of the cuck
stop it
brian
the fact you shamelessly say it out loud
the fucking sprinkle on top of the cuck
oop the cupcake
fucks sake
thank you strunnies trainer
my fucking main is in the gore
strunnie cuddle pop
stop that's such a cute nick name
oh my god
that's such a cute fucking nick name
yeah
what is this
everyone calls you mummy
but how do you feel about being babyed
I want to spoil you for the work you do
for being so gosh darn adorable
I'll take it either way
I'll serve it
y'all just put your minds on the gutter
strunnie cuddle pop
aww there's one here
she actually can't talk
the lonesome girl
what the dung eater from Elden Ring
wait
okay what's this one
I've been thinking about your desire to be seen as
just one of the girls
are you squidding me right now
aww it's not possible
what a good little puppy deserve all the head hacks
fuck
brian
I'm gonna need you to shut the up
okay brian you need to knock it off
do I make myself clear
thank you really listen
still can't get over the
I need to
I need to redirect
into sheebie into hours
okay
and I'm gonna go lie down for a nap
because I'm not allowed to do anything
until
no I literally
I'm not letting myself do anything
I'm waiting until after the pictures
because I was gonna wait until
I get a few marshmallows
and then do it
I kinda wanted to do a series
but I don't know how to prove
that I'm doing it without being
like
nah I'm not allowed to do anything
wow you really are a good girl
you're done
you can stream snipe
are you squidding me right now
these are so done
when the fricken
when the food bowl and the caller
and the leash and all that arrive
you guys are so done
okay you're
you're finished
do you understand me
thank you the booty lord
don't say thank you
you're a fucking
you guys are so
finished
finished you're on the wind
off
who's wearing the collar
I got a dog
I think
we're all finished
so
are you squidding me right now
I can't even
meet the marshmallows making me cry
no I can't read
anything
stop it
oh I can't read anything
I can't do anything
I can't
I'm stun logged
I'm fucking stun logged
Brian's piece of meat
Mr. Lake good girl
are you squidding me right now
no
I'm stun logged
I can't do anything
thank you
scrawny's trainer
thank you pv
thank you sariah
thank you scrumptious nightmare
we're just in puppy love with our good
I can't do anything
everything I read is
tingling
stop it
you're making me tingle
right
I'm gonna read that right now
because I can't do anything
I can't
it's too hard
I'm gonna read that right
to sheeby's haydee
okay
thank you for all the nice words
I'm sorry
I can't think straight when I'm like this
I love you I'm sorry
for being a kuma
okay
I'm gonna get our rest
and then I'll see you later for a recession
on again
and then after that
we're gonna do really bad stuff
are you squidding me right now
I can't
I can't take anyone
I need to hold off until
until the full
they put it on your tongue and gently
in your mouth
are you squidding me right now
my little pup is so cute
I might have to give her a treat
you're stun locking me
it's over
thank you Zarian
thank you anonymous
thank you Kalker
no more okay
no more
okay I'm gonna go
and try and calm down
because I will make a promise
that I won't do anything
until after the full
okay
I'm a kuma
by go
I'm literally throbbing
I'm gonna go riftlin
I love you I'll see you later
in today I give you kiss
no
no stun locking again
because this is too hard
I can't do it
are you squidding me right now
to counter everyone else
please milk me mama
use the pent up Scottish rage
from monkey ball to our words
I can't reply to that
thank you tiny spanish
I'll see you later today okay
and then later in the evening
bye
I see you
love from your very good pop